there's been a lot of talk about whether
Russia may have influenced the u.s.
presidential election that's been
dominating the news but there's another
big story coming out of Russia eight
different Russian diplomats have died in
the last five months alone some of them
died under very mysterious circumstances
now it could just be a coincidence but
it's certainly worth looking into
suspicious so I decided to ask someone
in the Russian press office about all
these mysterious deaths this was
expensive we got him via satellite
we got him via satellite please welcome
sir Jay stanislav sir Jay okay sir Jay
thank you for being here there's just
great things Conan the displeasing to
make your acquaintance ship okay very
good hard word for you Russians well I
won't sugarcoat it these are very
serious allegations it's been suggested
to Vladimir Putin is assassinating
people with too much information on him
very active imagination Conan all of
those deaths occur from natural causes
all right but many of the people who
died were critics of Putin not the
possible Vlad these world's number one
box I know him well
actually one weird thing about Putin
that nobody knows is Sergey Sergey are
you okay sir Jay are you okay yes yes go
tonight I'm fine I apologize for the
commotion I'm sorry you're not the same
guy we're sir Jay Sanjay I mean I was
talking too much and very out of line
will not happen again okay very strange
well I was gonna ask about the Russian
opposition leader who was shot outside
his hotel last week shot no no that was
the accident he mistake a bullet for an
old friend and tried to give it a ha
that's ridiculous
no it's true I know Putin well would you
like to hear a secret about mr. Putin
that nobody knows yeah sure of course
sergej Serge are you there sorry Conan I
who is there J was talking too much
again
you know I can it's pretty clear you're
a woman what you think all Russian women
have beards very racist stereotype Conan
whatever can you tell me about the
Russian intelligence officer who was
found dead in his car the police never
issued a cause of death
well yeah cause of death was listening
to favorite song on radio his heart so
full of happiness its explode not
Houten's fault actually an interesting
fact about Putin that nobody knows is
George a sturgeon that looks like a
grenade no no he's just a friendly bird
hello bird okay no you should be kept
Thursday sergej stare Jay gives me Serge
they would've do Conan
you're not surging you have no Russian
accent and you're black look what do you
want for me man I'm sorry Jay okay
whatever
I assume you can't tell me anything
about Putin then huh
actually I know to do an interesting
flaw about Putin and nobody knows
everyone I'm sorry that was very decide
you yes call coming it's me Sergey wait
a minute you're the guy who got shot
with the poisoned Dart earlier it was
not poisoned was vodka is Russian circle
of life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you